thank you all for
joining me with me today um i'll be
going through a
live demo as well as some examples and
kind of background about why r is very
exciting
how you can get started and kind of a
immediate plan and then a long term plan
about how to be successful using r
for statistical programming
so first off a little bit about me uh
who am i this is my face if you haven't
seen me before i met me in person
um i originally got started with
statistics
and using statistical analysis as a
master's student
i was doing exercise physiology looking
at how
exercise was beneficial for brain health
now when i first got started using
statistics i was using mainly
point-and-click interfaces things like
spss
excel origin so
a couple different things my statistics
and spss uh my data cleaning and
organization in excel and then finally
my plotting
in origin so it often meant that i had
to kind of change things around or flip
them when i was switching between
programs
eventually i ended up in a phd program
where i was analyzing
mouse behavioral data with the
neurobiology program
and this is where i really got my first
taste of r we had a intro to statistics
course um
in my second year and we used r uh for
some of the basics in that course
and once i got started with r i was like
oh this is really exciting i like the
statistical programming aspect where i
was doing coding
and doing everything in r rather than
having to switch between a lot of
different programs
and got interested in data science
through that
while i had that course i did find that
uh
i needed to learn a lot more beyond that
was just you know
given to me in this one month or so this
two month long course
so i actually got involved with the r
for ds or r for data science online
learning community
which is still around today um and
basically it's a slack group where
people are able to go in
uh share questions interact or code or
just you know share ideas
and out of this i was born the tidy
tuesday project
which is a weekly data project and i
help host this where
every week i upload a data set uh
community members you know
attack it with r and the tidy first
create plots or statistical analyses
and then share the examples on twitter
and it's been a really good project for
kind of continuous learning
in terms of every week there's a new
data set so you can you know
try things out in a different way than
you're used to rather than doing the
exact same thing over and over
as well as it's a distributed community
so even if you don't have local people
who are using are around you
you can learn online with an online
community
and lastly i joined our studio about a
year ago i'm on the customer success
team as rob mentioned
and what i do is help our professional
customers better use our professional
products as well as open source products
to use our in their enterprise settings
what i really want you to get out of
this is that you know my journey might
be similar to yours
in terms of um a lot of people get
started with r
didn't start as computer scientists or
didn't start as
programming in other languages this was
their first experience
uh with using statistics and programming
together
and that's kind of who i i'm
anticipating will be a lot of the crowd
today maybe we'll have some experienced
our users and they can also get
something from this
but i primarily aim this at people who
are just getting started with r
so maybe you've heard of r or you've
heard of our studio uh you've heard of
the tidy verse but
when you first started to get you know
trying to get started with r
you faced some hurdles and so you wanted
to you know find some more examples
about how to get started and be more
powerful
and this really resonated with me and
the kind of the basis for what this
presentation started as was a blog post
i wrote a year ago
based off this tweet by jesse who helped
found rfids online learning community
and basically she proposed that you know
if you'd started r
and didn't end up continuing with it
what were your stumbling blocks
and some of the common things that
resonated with me was things like this
uh you know i didn't have examples of
code or people doing the basic things
they need to do
you know basic multivariate stats and i
wasn't experienced enough
for david here you know interested in r
but for a lot of people
it was too high levels maybe they
weren't ready for full-blown
enterprise level data science they were
just trying to get started with you know
basic statistical programming and using
the tidy first to create some plots
or do some statistical analyses and
lastly my contribution was i know it can
be frustrating you know you're just like
hey i just want to run my anova and r
you know getting the data in cleaning it
up getting everything set up can often
be a hurdle for a lot of people and i
know back in the day it was a hurdle for
myself
i'm borrowing this graph curve here from
jd long who is a
data scientist out in the world a great
guy if you
have a chance you should look at some of
his presentations that he gave that
our studio con 2018 or 2019 and
basically the premise of this graph
is that there's this learning curve and
as with anything
when you initially you know get started
with learning something new
you're here at the what they quote the
suck threshold in terms of things are
hard and you're not very powerful
with a bad learning curve you'll
actually see that you stay here
in this kind of not being able to do
much powerful things for a long time
so the goal for today is to get us on
this good learning curve where you're
able to get into this point of i'm
kicking ass i'm doing powerful things
i'm creating something useful in r and i
i
feel powerful and hopefully this will
kind of get you started on on this good
journey versus the bad trade
it may have been stuck upon previously
so first of all why i think the biggest
thing for me is
people connect with an amazing community
often when you're doing
stats or programming it might be all by
yourself
in terms of you could be siloed in an
academic setting or maybe
other people in your workplace or using
just sql or excel or some other language
so you're able to connect with this
larger community ask them questions and
kind of gain access to their expertise
whether it's through things like
linkedin or twitter or
you know other different resources like
stack overflow or studio community
additionally programming itself is
basically a superpower that everyone has
access to
programming can kind of level up your
skill set over something like a
graphic user interface and allow you to
do things more efficiently
the thing for me that i really liked was
that i could do cleaning
analyzing plotting and finally
communication around my data all in one
place
so i didn't have to switch between a
bunch of different software suites and
pay for a bunch of different software
suites i was able to do everything in r
reproducibility is a big thing with
statistical programming in terms of
your kind of data product is based off
of code
so you kind of have an example of
exactly what you did rather than
having to ask somebody well hey what did
you do to clean up this data and they're
like oh i don't know it was a year ago
with you know code you're able to
actually reference exactly what you did
and see what's going on you do things
like automation where if you have a
repeated report you can just rerun your
code with new data
and it will update that report for you
and obviously it's free
you know r is an open source language
it's extremely powerful and all the
packages that add additional features to
r
are also free so it's a great investment
at the very beginning
uh we actually ran a survey right before
our last uh
our studio conference and asked people
what uh they liked best about r
and again the community packages the
tidy verse
gtaplod these were some things that were
very popular
uh amongst users so being able to be
powerful quickly
and engaging with the community is
something that really resonates across
groups
lastly kind of hitting again on why you
should you know be excited about the
community is
as kim says here you know because it's
fun and you can learn so much without
having to seek it out so you're just
able to kind of passively take
information and learn a lot by what
other people are doing
uh luda over here has some other
examples in terms of oh i can actually
help
someone out who's you know six months
behind me in their learning process
or commiserate over something that's
difficult uh thank somebody
see examples of database or other uh
excellent resources
so hopefully this kind of reinforces
that the community is great
and you're able to access them and kind
of interact with them
getting into kind of exactly what we're
covering today we'll be looking at the
basics of our studio
reading data into our basics of data
wrangling
some exploratory data analysis basic
statistics in r
and finally creating a publication plot
this resonates pretty well with the
total rfds model that hadley wickham and
garrett brolmann
kind of laid out and are for data
science their textbook
in terms of often uh statistical
workflows can look like this where you
bring your data
into our you tidy or clean it up somehow
and then you go through the cycle
of visualizing modeling statistical
testing
and transformation of data eventually
creating a data product that you
communicate
whether it's our markdown or shiny or
just a simple plot
and all this is wrapped around by
programming in terms of
rather than having to point click and do
all these other things you're able to
write a you know flow and syntax in in
our
and it will create these things for you
and be able to work through the workflow
here
i really want to emphasize that the
other things that we're not doing today
which is covering what statistical tests
to run when
we will not be doing a deep dive into
statistical programming or data science
in terms of
scaling it out to the enterprise and i
don't expect you to 100 get it the first
time this is just the start of your
journey and i'm hoping to kind of
again get you on that good learning
curve and get you started down a path
where you're able to be successful
quickly
and again that's the ultimate goal is
just eventually you will you'll reach a
point where you're like hey this is
really useful
i'm actually being powerful with this
and you'll feel rewarded in what you're
doing
as far as r and kind of getting into the
meat of the presentation i wanted to
emphasize the difference between r and r
studio
so if you think of r it could be the
engine of your vehicle
so it actually will do all the
computation for you it is actually the
code that you're writing
and executing whereas our studio the ide
or integrated development environment is
just an interface to that
engine it allows you to have a nice
place to work
and write code some user enhancements
that i'll walk through
but r itself is executing everything
this basic example of the rstudio cloud
interface
shows you the two kind of examples so
the console
would be the interface directly to r so
you can write some code here
you execute it and this actually created
a plot as its output you can also have
outputs that are you know more numeric
or text-based those can output in the
console
but this right here itself would be the
rstudio interface
i'll walk through this we'll actually do
a live coding demo i just wanted you to
get a very brief overview of what this
looks like
the other thing i wanted to cover before
we jumped into live coding was the
difference between r
and r packages so you can think of r as
a new phone you know it's powerful it
has some core features
like you know calling texting email
a web browser but you need to add
additional applications to do more
things
and ours is exactly the same way where
you can install packages that add new
features
so things like the tiny burst whether
it's dplyr or ggplot
allow you to get new features that you
can then use
in r and with that
i'd like to swap over into the live demo
so again let's see if i make this full
screen
this will be the rstudio cloud interface
i'll zoom in a little bit there so this
is actually
a hosted version of our studio so we
have an option of installing it on your
desktop
um you can do that after the fact and
kind of see
you know using it locally on your own
machine
but i wanted to start with our studio
cloud because i'm actually going to
share this workspace with you and you'll
be able to interact with the exact same
code
and data that i'm using and you'll be
able to try it out without it without
having to install anything
so here again is the rstudio interface
so if we were to work directly in the
console we could do some math
so we're you know typing some code and
we just do three plus three and you get
your output of six
it's often more useful rather than
having to write long functions in the
console
to rather write with them inside a
script or inside in our markdown
document
so here you're able to you know write
out longer things i have you know
50 lines of code here and i can write
some comments and do some things i'm
still able to execute
the code that i have so again the three
plus three i get my output of six
uh the other thing i want to cover real
quickly is base r functions and objects
so you can do math or do anything else
and assign it to an object so in this
case
we'll assign three plus five to x and
then we could actually
call x and we can see that it will then
execute the math
additionally we can see that x has been
stored as a value here in our
environment
so when you're working with data sets
and i'll import a data set here in a
little bit
you can actually find them here in the
rstudio environment pane so that can be
useful
if you're not used to like you know
finding where your data sets are always
look up here in the top right for your
environment
you can also do some other things like
combine data set or numbers so here you
know one through five is now stored as y
and there's some functions that are just
built into r things like sequence which
actually will generate
a sequence of numbers uh so 0 to 10
and it will iterate by 2 so 0 2 4 6 8 10
these are things that are all built into
r additionally you can write your own
functions which is where a lot of power
comes from
in terms of i'm going to create a
function here called add pi
and this function just basically says
take something that i input
and add 3.14 to it so if i save this
and add pi to it we can see that 3 plus
3.14
gets us the 6.14
now when we're talking about these
functions you may not use functions for
quite a while
um but a lot of libraries are actually
built off of these functions so they
give you more interfaces where
rather than having to type this out
itself you just call add pi
and similarly if we use a library which
is a collection of functions
we can load it and this now gives us a
bunch of plotting functions
based off of the ggpot library this will
take a data set
in this example a cars data set
and allow you to kind of set up a graph
so if i actually just run the code here
it will input a graph and you can see
that i have a graph of horsepower versus
miles per gallon
and then a linear model fit to it in a
title
the real big thing that i love about r
and a lot of the tidy versus functions
is that this is very word based or verb
based
so i can look at this and say okay well
i want my x-axis to be horsepower
and it's horsepower i want my y-axis to
be miles per gallon
and you can see it's miles per gallon
and then i want to add
points to that plot so if i just call
this part right here
we can see that graph of horsepower
versus miles per gallon and have the
nice plots here
we can then add more features to it so
adding things like the gm smooth or that
linear model fit
and then changing the titles so that
they look nicer rather than saying hp
and mpg
you know adding them back so they say
horsepower and miles per gallon
i'm covering this pretty quickly and
part of this will be able
you know able to reference it in the
future but just kind of going through
that as a quick example
i'm also going to load the tidy verse
library which has a lot of other
functions and other
libraries within it mainly the ones
we're looking at are deep plier and tidy
r which are used for data cleaning and
transformation
and ggplot which already loaded which
allows you to create plots
the last thing i want to cover related
to tidyverse is the pipe function
which you can think of as and then so if
you're reading
some code so here i want to take the
code here and i'm going to say i'm going
to take the data frame cars data set
and then i'm going to mutate cylinder
into a factor
and then i'm going to select the columns
miles per gallon
cylinder displacement and horsepower
so if we look at the uh let's scroll
this down
if we look at the data frame cars data
set before we do anything else you can
see that it has a lot of columns
so miles per gallon all the way up to
carb
and we can see that cylinder is labeled
here as a double which actually means
that it's as a numeric value
when we do this transformation here we
take that data set
and then change cylinder to be a factor
and then select only these four columns
you can see that it will actually change
the data set so now
cylinder is labeled as a factor and you
only have the four columns of interest
the tidy versus based around these
functions where you have you know
nice verbs to work with that allow you
to kind of
understand what you're doing even if
you're just getting started
so yes this may seem a little
intimidating right now but you are able
to to work through these functions and
kind of get a sense of what you're
trying to accomplish
and then again we can take that same
data set and create a plot with it
so this point instead of doing a gm
point
i use gm box plot which allows you to
create
a quick box plot and then overlay
another jitter
or jitter dot points all over the graph
here
so we went over the quick basics here
the console and i also wanted to show
you again the environment
so those data sets i was working with in
this example small df
you can see that it's here listed inside
your environment pane
so you can see the small df and you can
see that it only has the four columns
versus our full data set that we were
working with earlier
has a lot of different columns the 11.
you are able to uh to look at this kind
of like in an excel
format so if you were to do view small
df
you'll actually open it in a new tab or
you can scroll through it and kind of
look at it in a long format that you
want to
you can also go into here and just click
the uh
this pane here and it will do the exact
same thing so open up
the data sets you're able to take a look
at it
so we covered the r basics pretty
quickly um
the again the kind of
origin of this whole talk was based off
a blog post i wrote
back on my blog here and what's
interesting is this covers
a fake data set about alzheimer's
disease and then
giving these patients a drug and seeing
how it changed their cognitive function
i wrote this whole blog post in r so you
see all these graphs and text
this whole thing was written in r so
as an example of kind of the power of
which you could do i can actually just
rerun this whole report
and create that blog post again and you
see in about 20 seconds
or five seconds two seconds uh i've
recreated that entire thing so all the
text
adding the pictures re-running all the
code making the plots
all that's been recreated quickly so
this is one of the powers of code
in terms of you're able to reproduce
what you've been working on
as a basic example we can think of
alzheimer's disease as a decline in
cognitive function
due to changes in brain so your brain
actually deteriorates
as you age with this disease and for
example we're looking
at a novel drug and we're giving it a
couple different doses to males and
females and seeing how it changes their
cognitive function
so that's kind of the context isn't
super important it's just a data set
that we'll be using
uh but at least kind of giving you a
sense of what we're getting started with
is that better perfect thank you perfect
okay
uh i did want to let you know that as we
get started with this
uh second file that this is actually an
r markdown document
and if we compare that to uh our r file
here
you can see that you know the text if we
were to write it out
uh gives you you know this error because
it's trying to evaluate this code
with our mark there's an intent of
saying
i'm going to write text here that is you
know describing what i'm doing or
talking through what the results are
and then each of these code chunks here
will actually allow you to evaluate code
as you would
expect so for the first example what we
want to do
is load our libraries so again these
will add new functions
to 2r so we have the tidy first for
plotting cleaning
and other functions like that the broom
package which cleans up statistical
outputs and make them a little bit
cleaner
knit r which is some tables and our
markdown outputs
the read excel package to read in excel
files
and then the here package which allows
you to do programmatic
kind of aiming at data sets to read them
in or
file structures so we'll load these
and they've been loaded now so the next
step would be to read in the data
so with other uh kind of interfaces you
might you know go into
file and open a data set you are still
able to do that in in
our studio so you can tell our studio
either programmatically so write out
code saying
i want to save a data set known as raw
df
and i want to read it in as an excel
file so if i do this
it will add the raw df data frame in so
it's read in a new excel file
or if maybe you wanted to do it
not programmatically you could also
import a data set
so go to file import data set and then
go to excel
you can then browse and then choose a
data set of interest so here we're
looking at the 80 treatment
open it and it will give you a preview
of what the data set looks like
the code to actually read it in and then
you can import
it that way as well because
i know exactly what the data set is i
just did it programmatically so again
i use the read xls function and i read
in the data set as xlsx
it's stored up here and if i want to i
can take a quick look at that
using the glimpse function which just
shows you an overview
so it says how many observations there
are number of variables and then gives
you
a quick peek at what the actual
variables are
so this is actually uh you know the top
five or ten examples
across the data set
now that we've got it loaded into r we
can actually start using it
so again using something like ggplot we
can say okay we want to use the data raw
df
which is the same data that we just
loaded and we want to assign
a mini mental status exam or cognitive
function to be on the x axis
i'm then going to add the geom density
function which
would tell it to create a density plot
which is kind of a
similar to a histogram and we can see
the distribution
of a cognitive function across our
patient examples
so this is kind of quick exploratory
analysis you can see it's very small
amount of code
you're really just saying what data set
uh what are your axes
and then what kind of plot do you want
to make and it will quickly make this
plot for you
and this shows us that we have kind of a
bi-modal distribution
we have a group of patients that have a
low mini mental status exam so lower
cognitive function
compared to this patient population
which has a higher kind of function
closer to about 25.
now that we've got kind of an
exploratory graph maybe you want to take
a look
at the um some basic stats about it
so we can actually run a new function so
again taking
the raw df and then summarizing it
the summarize function from dplyr will
actually say okay
take this data set and then you know
knock it down to just these two values
so i want to look at the min and the max
let me see the min here is 8.4 so that's
the lowest mini-mental status exam value
and the highest is about 28. but you
know this just shows you the
the raw range across it that's not all
that useful
so we can actually do a second function
here
we can use group by so rather than
uh just doing it you know across the
whole data set
we can actually group it by health
status where the health status actually
will show
you know alzheimer's patients versus
healthy patients
so we run this the raw df group by
health status
and then for our summarize we want to
get the min value the median value
and the max value where these correspond
to other code to get started with
here that are part of base r so we can
see that the alzheimer's patients
generally have a lower uh range so they
have
men of 8.4 the median's about 15 and the
max about 25
compared to healthy patients we can see
all these are above 20
for their mini mental status exam
so that's pretty interesting but maybe
we want to see something more about the
data set
so we'll look at you know account so
kind of a table function of how many of
each we have
so again taking the raw df data frame
and then
grouping by both drug treatment and
health status
where we have a couple different doses
of the drug we use a high dose
a low dose and then a placebo and we
give this to all of our patients that
either have alzheimer's or
healthy patients and we can see that we
have a hundred
of each of these groups so each of the
groups have an equal amount of
uh you know subjects in them so it's a
well well set up study here
when we're thinking more about summary
statistics it might be helpful to kind
of get into some additional graphs
so rather than just doing a raw
distribution we might look at it by
a few different uh groupings so again
something more similar to where the drug
treatment
versus the health status example
so in this case we have ggplot and we're
loading our data set of interest raw df
we're taking on the x axis drug
treatment
so either high dose low dose or placebo
and then on the y-axis or the dependent
variable
we'll look at mini-mental status exam
and then
we'll assign color to be drug treatment
this will basically say that there will
be uh you know three different colors
here so
each of the drug treatments will get to
be a different color rather than all the
same
we're gonna build a box plot
sorry about that box plot showing the
different examples
of the min median and the range
and then we're going to facet this or
create small multiples
according to health status
so if we go here we can see for
alzheimer's versus healthy patients
we can see a nice graph of
the mini-mental status exam so the high
dose
the low dose and the placebo uh and then
here in the healthy patients again the
distribution
around that so the median and the upper
quartiles for the high dose low dose and
placebo
something i do want to point out is that
uh you know these
axes aren't you know super pretty in
terms of the drug treatment has you know
a symbol in it mini mental sas exam it's
all
lower case and we'd probably want to
flip this so placebo low dose and high
dose
are are arranged differently rather than
it going from high to low
go from placebo to high but we do have a
sense of there appears to be a
difference in that
the healthy patients regardless of
treatment appear to be
having higher mse scores
compared to the alzheimer's patients
where the placebo has a low
mmse and the low dose the high dose
increase it slightly
with that treatment there
again just taking a quick look at the
raw data frame
we can see uh rerunning this function
we have age sex health status
drug treatment and then mmse as our
dependent variable
it's important to note that these
variables here are actually labeled as
just
text or character and we actually want
to save those as a factor which assigns
them you know
a tier or kind of a categorical label as
opposed to just raw text
these are numeric or double so we can
leave them as is
except for sex is coded as zero or one
where zero is male and one is female so
we do want to do some data cleaning here
to get everything off the ground
correctly
so we'll actually create a new uh data
frame or new
object here so sum data frame we're
going to take the original raw data
frame
and then mutate it where we're changing
sex to be a factor
and the levels are going to be zero and
one and then we're going to assign
labels to that
of male and female so basically it will
go through
r will read and say okay there's a zero
here this will now be
uh male there's a one here so this will
be assigned female
and we'll change that and then assign it
as a factor
we're also going to change drug
commitment into a factor so we're going
to mutate
drug treatment to be a factor against
drug treatment
where the levels are going to be placebo
low dose and then high dose
so we're actually putting in the correct
order we want to see
lastly we're also going to mutate health
status to be a factor
around health status where the levels
are going to be healthy and then
alzheimer's
so if we run this code we can see that
the same kind of glimpse here that we
look at the data
so the variables all look the same but
it says male here as opposed to zero
and here's that one and so there should
be a female and we see a female
and these are also labeled as a factor
so health status and drug treatment
and sex are all labeled as factors now
so that's good because it gets us set up
for our future analyses whether it's
statistics or
or plotting so again
uh we're going to create a summary table
here
so again this is all the data set
so when we're doing our summary data
frame we want to take a look at
us you know means or medians or uh you
know
standard error and then the amount of
samples
so that's what we're doing here is
taking the original uh
data frame and reassigning it as the
same name
we're going to group this so basically
take all of these
group it by sex health status and drug
treatment
and then summarize around our functions
of interest
so we'll get the mean we'll get the
standard error as calculated by standard
deviation
by the square root of n and then show
the number of samples by using the
n function which is for number lastly
we'll also
tell it to ungroup so that it takes away
that grouping variable after it's
already calculated
so if we run this code then we can look
at some df again
we can see that rather than having 600
observations we've now gone to 12
observations so basically
the different groups so male healthy
placebo male healthy low dose
female healthy placebo female healthy
low dose all these have the mean
the standard error and the number of
samples calculated out
so this is helpful in terms of we've got
our nice summary statistics saved here
and we're ready to work with those
whether it was plotting or just you know
saving those as a table itself
if we wanted to we could save it at this
point so using our
fake drug adx 37 the summary stats we
could save that as a csv
we're just going to keep working since
we know that we're not stopping here
if we did want to create kind of a
summary plot of that we can again take
that data frame
so the sum df rather than the raw df
that we've been working with previously
and again assign an x and a y axis
so here we're taking the x-axis drug
treatment
the y-axis as mini-mental status exam
mean
we're going to assign a group which
basically groups those those numbers
together
uh drug treatment and then a color of
drug treatment
so we can see that we get three colors
as opposed to to one
we're going to increase the size of the
gm point so we're going to add
points to our plot and make them a
little bit bigger so if this were say
one they'd be nice and tiny
but we want it to be a little bit bigger
so we'll do it as three
and lastly we're actually going to
rather than make
one plot where they're all kind of sorry
they're all overlaid here
we're going to facet it or create small
multiples so facet grid
and we're going to make it where it's
sex by health status
so if we rerun that code we can see that
now it's separated out into four plots
rather than one
where male and female are here we have
the healthy and alzheimer's patients
and then we finally see the placebo low
dose high dose for the drug treatment
and we can see the kind of different
comparisons for the male and female
versus healthy and alzheimer's so we're
getting closer to a publication plot
here
um but it's still a little rough
we're finally getting to the anova in
terms of walking through that kind of
slowly and getting set up with
the actual statistical analyses now so
for this example we're going to create a
new data frame called stats data frame
since we already saved this as a summary
level so actually create a new data set
we'll start again with raw df we'll do
our mutate again so we'll change drug
treatment to be a factor
sex to be a factor and health status to
be a factor
so that's ready to go for the anova so
we'll rerun this
and again we can see with glimpse that
statsdf our new data set
is saved as a factor across the board
and this is now labeled as male and
female
as opposed to zero and one
the actual uh code for running a nova at
least a type 1
sum of squares is pretty simple in terms
of the basic setup
is use the aov or anova function
you assign the dependent variable first
use a tilde
and then the independent variable and
you tell it what is the data set of
interest so here we're using a fake data
set data df
if you want to do main effects or
interactions there are there is a slight
variation there so for just main effects
you will add your dependent variable
your independent variable one so here
sex drug treatment
health status are all added individually
as main effects
or you can do main effects and
interactions by using
a star instead of a plus sign
there's a couple different ways of doing
anovas i'm just showing one example here
and there's a whole lot of
other different statistical tests that
you can do in r
so again this is just a basic example
and there's some textbooks i'll be
sharing about
uh great examples of going through
choosing a different statistical test or
approaching it from a
statistical validity standpoint just
trying to get us started with
the basic setup here i did want to point
out that
you can use the plus or the star but we
don't want to use commas here this would
actually throw an
error and that's okay it doesn't break
anything it just says you know
it's not able to do this because it's
trying to assign this in an improper way
so always make sure and use a plus to
add only main effects or the star for
the main effects and interactions
so we'll run it as the main effects and
interactions and now we can say
that it saved our alzheimer's disease
anova
as a list object here and there's a
bunch of things going on
and i will show what all those different
things are here in one second
so if we actually call summary on that
uh
object adaob you kind of get a nice
table
here of what you would expect to see you
know your degrees of freedom sum of
squares mean square your f value
and then your p value and it also tells
you the significance levels whether it's
point one or all the way down to zero
so we can see that there are significant
main effects uh
as well as an interaction of drug
treatment by health status so we'll
follow up with those
but this kind of output here is not
always
the most useful in terms of working with
it in other ways so we can actually
tidy this up with the broom package and
if we were to look
at tidy ada anova
we can see that it's in a different
format now it's a little bit cleaner
so rather than having this uh kind of
asic output
we've got it in a nice data frame where
it's you're able to see all the
different things kind of across
a little bit cleaner and again you could
save this to excel
or as a csv if you wanted to export it
or you can just kind of keep it here
because we did see manifest interactions
we should follow up with post hoc tests
so we'll take a look at a couple
different post hoc test examples
the first one would just be a pairwise
t-test with the bonferroni correction
and the basic setup here to take a look
is that we're going to save it as an ad
pairwise so we know which one we
this was the pairwise t-test function
gets us started
and we're going to assign a statsdf um
with
mmse as our json of interest where mmse
is the dependent variable
and then we've got a little bit weirder
syntax here that's hard to read but i'll
walk through with it
so again we're using the statsdf data
frame and we're using the
sex column as the factor we're doing an
interaction
shown here with the colon
and then using the next factor which is
drug treatment
another colon for the interaction and
then the stats df
and the health status column and lastly
telling it to do
a p-value adjustment for multiple
comparisons of bonferroni
so we run that and we can again see that
it's saved as an object
again i like to clean this up a little
bit so i'll run tidy on it
so we use the broom package to to tidy
it and i'm actually going to then
mutate the p value to round it so it's
uh
less expansive rather than sig figs we
kind of get this nice just five
significant units
so we can see the comparison here where
we're saying comparison one
male placebo alzheimer's compared to
male placebo healthy
is significantly different as opposed to
the low dose and the healthy male
versus the placebo and the healthy male
not something statistically
significantly different
that's just the quick example of the
bonferroni
if maybe you like the two key tests
better you can also do that
so here we're using the 2key hsd
function
we're using the ad anova data set we've
already created
so that was our actual anova output from
above and this syntax is a little bit
cleaner where we say
run a tukey on this anova where
the interaction of sex drug treatment
and health status statuses of interest
we're then going to tidy it to clean it
up like this
take just the first six values with head
and create a nice table
so if i do this we can again see that we
have our term
the comparison here so female placebo
healthy versus male placebo healthy
it's got your confidence intervals uh
low and high
and then the adjusted p value here for
the two key tests
these are gonna be pretty similar to the
bonferroni because the comparisons are
sorry the groups are very very different
um but
you'll obviously need to choose
whichever statistical test makes sense
for your
analysis lastly in the next couple of
minutes i'm going to go through
a quick guide to the publication graph
so
uh i'm actually going to create a data
set and actually
can create this with the triple function
where
i can assign a column and then all the
different values in it
so if i run this function here you can
see that column a gets a
b and c a b and c and column b
gets one two three one two three in it
we assign the column names by adding a
tilde before it and then each of the
columns below it get added correctly
rather than just adding kind of random
data i'm going to
assign these as the proper groups so i
actually looked back through the
pairwise comparisons above
and found the groups that were
significantly different so the low-dose
alzheimer's male
and the high-dose alzheimer's male
versus the placebo
and then the low-dose alzheimer's female
the high-dose alzheimer's female versus
placebo is significantly different
so we're creating a new data set based
around that
and then reassigning our factor levels
there so we see drug treatment
sexist factor and health status as a
factor as well
we're finally getting to that
publication plot and it looks a lot uh
wordier or longer than our plots from
above that's because we're doing some
uh more customization
so if we look at the actual plot here
and i'll pull it up in the window so you
can see it nice and big
there we go you can see
a few different things so we're doing
our basic setup where we have our data
as the sum data frame
we're assigning x as the drug treatment
and why as the
mini mental status exam mean we're going
to fill it or
assign a color according to drug
treatment and group it by drug treatment
and then we're going to add error bars
so this
white gray black is according to the
fill and then we've assigned the error
bars which are really small here
according to group i built out that
data set above here because i'm actually
assigning
small asterisks to the graph
and that can be found with the gm text
i've assigned here
so this is data according to the sig fig
data frame that we set up
and adding a label of an asterisk
i also changed a couple of athena theme
items so changing it to be a white
background versus a gray
uh changing the access text size all
these different things
are kind of at your discretion so maybe
you're like oh i
want to add these different changes or
make it a little bit prettier this would
be an example
i'm going to leave this here for you to
play around with so i will be sharing
that cloud
setup so you can actually take a look at
this and pull out different things and
try it out
but the basic idea is that you know we
create based off of the data set
we assign the column or sorry the x and
y axes
what type of graph do you want to make
an error bar a bar
graph and then we want to make small
multiples or multiple graphs according
to sex and health status where we see
sex and health status again lastly we'll
add our labels
so rather than kind of blah or or small
descriptors we have a nice big drug
treatment and cognitive function
and then a figure caption here so figure
one the effect of novel drug treatment
with our uh groups and the total n
as well as a significant indicator
lastly we can take that graph that we
saved as g1
give it a nice title so 80 publication
graph
assign a height a width units for that
and then a dpi the dpi indicates the
dots per inch which basically says
you know high quality as that increases
if you don't do that it might be a
little bit fuzzy as you can see this is
a little bit fuzzy
versus if we look at the publication
graph here
very nice and sharp and it's actually
very large and you can zoom in
and it looks good
i'll leave this part out and i think
we're good there
i really quickly want to go back into
our presentation now that we've covered
this and we'll walk through
the last few stages on what to do next
now that you've kind of gotten a
whirlwind walkthrough
of uh how to do statistics and some
live coding art so for the next steps
and the kind of the follow-up items that
might be helpful for you
i will be sharing the slides in the
rstudio cloud instance so you'll have
the availability of all this code and be
able to play around with this data set
in our studio cloud without having to
install anything you just do it through
your web browser
so you'll be able to kind of walk
through exactly what i did and play
around with it
additionally working inside our studio
cloud there's actually training
data sets and examples there so if you
go to rcdo cloud
primers it'll actually show you the
basics of how to get started with r
how to work with data do some
visualization tidying
iteration which is more of high level
functional programming
and then writing functions themselves
which i covered very quickly
the good thing here is that these are
interactive so you're able to write code
and get feedback immediately
they're ready to go without having to
install anything and you can't break
anything
you don't have to worry about installing
something on a windows versus a mac
versus the linux box
it's just ready to go in your web
browser
there's additionally some great books if
you're trying to figure out okay which
statistical test do i need to use
learning statistics with r by danielle
navarro is a great book that covers kind
of the didactic
understanding of why statistics and
which to use as well as raw r code about
how to do them
the r for data science book actually
covers examples
of going through r for data science as
opposed to pure statistics so doing more
programming plotting exploratory data
analysis
this is a great textbook by hadley
wickham and garrett grolman
and if you're more interested just
purely in data visualization
social viz by karen healy is a great
resource for uh
seeing example r code to create these
beautiful plots and examples like you
saw today
the last thing i wanted to go over as
well was the tidy tuesday off for ds
online learning community
so this is that weekly project i talked
about briefly
basically a data set gets uploaded
weekly at
github so github r4ds tidy tuesday
every monday on twitter we release the
data set and it looks like this
so a link to the data an article about
the data and then some example plots
basically you just play around the data
and you can share it or just observe
what other people are doing on twitter
it's a great way to learn more about
using r and the tidy verse with
new data sets each week additionally
there's r studio community where you can
ask questions
so whether it's questions about the ide
or if you need help with actual code you
can go in here and ask questions there
the r for ds online learning community
has a slack group where you can also ask
questions and it's a little bit more
private since it isn't
a public-facing group every anyone can
join but you know it isn't
uh you have to log into slack at the
very least so it sometimes feels a
little bit
uh quicker to start as you're able to do
immediate interaction
and lastly r is pretty active on twitter
uh somebody actually collected
all the tweets using the r stats hashtag
um between 2008 and 2018 you can see
there's almost
500 000 or about 430 000 tweets
and there are additional um hashtags you
can follow whether it's rstats or
tidyverse ggplot
epidemiology twitter our spatial there's
there's a bunch of different
resources there
our opency has a lot of packages that
may be more specific to
your type of science so i covered one
example for kind of
neuroscience maybe you're doing you know
plant science or marine biology or
something
there could be other packages through
our open side that are useful and that's
just r opency.com
and lastly if you're trying to get
involved the our ladies global community
is great
and basically their mission is to
promote gender diversity in our
community
so this includes an advertisation of any
minority gender
you're able to join remotely or at
actual meetups in your city
and it's a great initiative to staying
involved
and contributing to this community
and lastly i know that this kind of was
very quick and it can seem intimidating
to
get started with r and maybe you're like
oh you know i'm
later in my career or i'm a little bit
older um
jenny bryan who i have a huge amount of
appreciation and respect for
uh was talking about this with sharla
and talking about how
everyone has their own career path and
it could be a slow career movement
or a fast career movement that's okay so
it kind of reinforces that
you don't have to get started super
quickly and you can kind of go through
it in a
at your pace and then lastly
uh obviously hadley whitcomb's pretty
well known in the art community
and he still google stuff and finds that
out through the rstats
so again no matter how experienced you
are it's okay to make mistakes it's okay
to be learning
and we're all here to learn with you so
with that i'll actually end a little bit
after time but still have some time for
questions
i appreciate your attendance today
and i'll take questions now thanks
so the key differences between rcdo
cloud and rstudio is our studio cloud is
hosted so you connect to it purely
through a web browser you don't have to
install anything
and then the rstudio desktop uh is
actually installed on your computer
whether it's your laptop or
your desktop computer both will look
exactly the same
once you're actually using them
okay some people ask about the tidy
verse library it's basically
a
so packages give you those functions
that allow you to uh you know do more
things in r without having to write it
by hand
and the tidy verse is a meta collection
of other packages
that uh follow along in that syntax
you can actually create websites using
our markdown it produces
html content so you can look at the blog
down or the
distill packages those actually allow
you to create entire websites or blogs
in r
and that's how i run my personal blog
there's some great resources
at block down there's actually a book
about it and distill has its own website
distill.rstudio.com
yep there we go so this actually walks
through kind of in long form exactly
what we covered today
um i didn't want to just read this uh
out in front of you but it basically
gives a similar presentation what i did
although i have changed it up a little
bit since then
but this could be useful if you maybe
don't like videos as much and you want
to read through something
you can just search for the
mockup.netlife.com
it's actually the first post i have
there
the tidyverse is one package but it's a
meta collection of packages
um you can actually uh
someone's asking about how do you know
which functions are available in each
package
a lot of packages will have their own
website or
a crayon page so if you think of like
the tidy verse
it actually
a website where you can look at all the
different things so it's just
tidyverse.org
you can look at the different packages
that are here and available
you can click on the individual packages
and there's everything from cheat sheets
to example usage where it has in the
life cycle
and then references to all the different
functions that are available
in it you can also do this from within
uh our studio cloud so if you
see if we get back in there i'll log
back in real quickly
yeah so you can actually just type um
some code it will kind of show you
exactly what that function is so if you
did like
question mark d plier or
question mark ggplot2 that will open up
in the help
pane an example about that so
it will give you links to external
resources
um as well as some information about the
package you can also do that same syntax
in terms of question mark
followed by the package name
and then tell it what are the functions
you're looking at so
let's do annotate so if i did on just
one function it will give a description
the example arguments that are available
the details and a quick example of it
uh you can label a factor as anything so
someone's asking about labeling a factor
as say like less than 24 as opposed to
24 written on its text
that label could be used as a character
so you could actually just type in
less than 24. so example like
factor x label
you know less than 24.
some something along those lines this
wouldn't actually give you the full code
but just an example of
this is now a character vector and could
be labeled that way
any of the free r training programs
courses moocs i'm a big fan of the
cloud workspace these primers because
you're able to do them
super quickly and for free in terms of
going to here to the basics
click on visualization and you're able
to get started with
both kind of example queries actually
running code
and it will give you outputs here so you
can you know
actually practice inside of a workspace
or just go through these primers
um i think that's
about it yeah a lot of similar questions
so i think i covered it